Oh shit, a professional.
Hello.
Hello everybody.
I'm a professional.
Hello.
If I sound tired, it's actually because I woke up an hour
ago.
I know I was not very ideal.
I know my sleep schedule is a little bit fucky-wucky right
now.
I did.
I had trouble sleeping.
till 5 a.m.
because like like um for those for the non-member goons um i
was yesterday for yesterday's stream it got pushed back uh i
think like three hours was it three hours one two three yeah
it was i it got pushed out uh pushed up three hours because
i couldn't sleep for nine hours last night i was tossing and
turning since uh 1 a.m to uh 10 a.m and um and then finally
was able to fall asleep um for today today i was also having
trouble falling asleep again um this time it was uh it was i
tried to go to bed at uh 2 a.m i was tossing and turning
until 4 a.m and then i was like fuck this i might as well
get work done if it's gonna be another 9 a.m situation or 10
a.m situation i might as well get it so i got up was on my
pc got some work stuff done but as much as I could do in an
hour and I finally felt tired because work always makes me
tired uh and I finally fell asleep and my manager was like
you're gonna record stuff in the morning when you wake up
right and I was like of course I am of course like I'm gonna
wake up like at a decent time like I have plenty of time to
wake up it's 5 p.m is my stream I woke up at 4 p.m um
um so about that instead I woke up at 4 p.m so I had no have
to record the things I have to record today.
So I'm sorry, my manager to my manager.
I'm sorry.
Mr. Manager, I'm sorry.
I didn't I didn't think I was gonna wake up at four.
I didn't think I was gonna sleep 12 hours, guys.
I in my head, I didn't think I was gonna.
I know I had a wild dream, but I can't remember this dream
this time.
Thank God.
Um, all right.
Long story short, fucking dream the member goons know what
i'm talking about yesterday i dreamed about trying to stop
hitler from taking over the world he was back um so
yesterday's dream but it wasn't just one hitler it was he
somehow it was like multiple hitlers so there was like a
group of them and me and a group of a team that was
assembled had to stop yeah he returned and then did you stop
him plot twist in the end um the dream was very wild um so
it was like me and a team of people were trying to stop a
group of hitlers from taking over the world because he was
back and he brought a team with by his own team with him and
and then in the end for some reason like half the team was
from the future or like we were all from i don't know i
don't know it was we were all from the future or half the
team was in the future but after we get our tasks done we
have to wrap back to the future and then um for the last
team i got my job done but the last team the last team they
had to um they had to like there was something went wrong
for the last team so each of us were assigned for a certain
point to start to stop a specific group of hitlers um for
like you know the hitlers had a team of two of each hitler i
guess like two hitlers per team and then we were a team of
two to stop their team and then i got my task done and then
you know it was like cs where person's body um to see what
their pov is type ds or like i control you know like you
know when you die in css um you get put onto into a bot so
like i got my but instead of you know all that i got my task
done and then i trans my soul pov was transported to the
last team to see what the fuck they're like the last team
has to get their last job done anyway so tldr for the last
team something went wrong and then one of the team members
was like you go back first don't worry i'll come back with
you um and they tied the tied like this the tape around them
and they were sent back to the future and they're like no we
were supposed to be a team we're supposed to do this
together and like like you know they're like you go back
first i'll be right behind you and then and then she got
sent back um into the future and she was like did she do it
did we do it
uh came out of the world the view was the like you know the
view was the city and then the hitlers came in it was like
good job men and then it's like no and then i woke up and
then i woke up so i don't know we stopped him i don't
So I can't be sure.
I wasn't.
Anyway, I know today I had a really wild dream because I
woke up and was like, what the fuck?
But unfortunately, unlike yesterday's dream, I don't know
what I forgot what the dream was.
Dango, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just, I forgot what the dream was.
But I knew it was fucking wild because when I woke up, I was
like, what the fuck?
I already forgot about it.
your ending um i might need another playthrough of this game
i might need to do another playthrough um of the dream um
anyway so today we're gonna be playing halo 2 uh like i said
for those who don't know i've never played halo before i
didn't grow up with an xbox uh my dad was a sony boy so uh
he was like no xbox in this house um until gears of warrior
came out then he got an xbox 360 uh but that was like he
didn't really care much about the xbox to me um so never
grew up with halo um so when i first played halo one with
you guys i was like what the fuck wait this game is about
zombies not aliens like i was not expecting i feel like i
feel like nobody's really talked about the zombies part of
the the halo experience I knew was about Ward Ward Ward
that's all I knew of that I didn't realize there was more to
it um so yeah going in blind I don't have any knowledge
about Halo 2 I am going in blind um regarding the entire
Halo series all I know is John Halo and his butt cheeks but
I don't think that was canon um Renato Renadro thank you for
the welcome to tomato farm welcome welcome Jakato thank you
the super chat thank you thank you um hey toky uh heads up
you're looking for a halo 2 2000 rock band soundtrack that's
only in a classic graphics not anniversary but thankfully
you can swap graphics whenever with tab oh yeah my swap
graphics strat where like if it gets too dark i just swap
the graphics i don't even remember i don't remember like or
when it gets oh yeah when it yeah when it yeah i just saw
the graphics when it gets too dark also i don't know if it's
you guys but um but google sorry youtube implemented a new
feature in youtube chat i don't know they're like slowly
implementing this but there's like a google translate option
if someone talks in different language but they've been
trying to translate word word word to word word word i so he
typed what what word it google translates automatically to
word word word because they're like what what language is
that from what and then someone's like look at it and it got
translated to like like well i need which is like chinese
where i love you and it's like look at it i don't know if
you guys see that there's this look at it But then the
Chinese meaning.
Yeah, so I can read this.
Word, word, word, word, word, word, word, word, word, word.
Oh, my God.
And then what is it?
Also, okay, wait, it's pretty silly.
You're like, all right, George, we're going to use you as a
test subject here.
I'll show you guys what it looks like.
It's really fucking dumb.
So, oh my God, I need to get a new monitor arm.
that for years but my honor this this is not it's just i
have this last legs right now my other monitor keeps falling
down all right let me grab it so you'd be thinking like oh
what did he translate this to he's like what is it and then
you hover over it it's like wait can i even do this if i
hover over it let's see oh shit nope give me a sec i'm gonna
see if i can finesse this no okay so you see that google
translate icon here all right god damn it okay i'm trying to
like view to speed so i can like instantly no hover because
i can't snip it when i'm hovering over it there you go yes i
got it all right here you go this is what it translates to
But you're like, what is it?
And then when you look in it, into it, it literally says
underneath.
Something that's not the actual translation.
What it, whoa.
So it's not accurate.
It's not, I think it depends on the language.
It's pretty bad.
That doesn't mean, what is it?
Not the real translation.
Caleb, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It is the eternal duty of Halo fans to not spoil the zombies
for Halo 1.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't know if you can disable it.
Has anyone figured it out?
How to disable that?
Here's another one.
Look at me.
There's...
You must be wondering.
I wonder what that translates to.
Look at this.
There's another one.
Look at me.
So you're like wondering, oh, what does that translate to?
It's funny that you say that
because...
Let me show you guys.
Funny you say that if you're curious about what that
translates to.
Also, one.
Also, the same one.
No way.
It's not even consistent.
Look at me.
So, I do hope that I can turn that off because apparently,
You guys are nice.
It's you guys are just trying to talk in a language and it's
not translating very well It's not translating well at all
I don't like this new update.
It should be like optional like what if I like I can like
what if I can read the language?
It should be optional in general It can spell it can
translate Canada, right?
They're like Canada Canada.
I saw that i saw someone spamming canada all right taylor
tab wait it doesn't matter because i'm gonna give me a sec
uh or oh my god it's on my other monitor all right give me a
sec i have to oh thank god i didn't oh thank god i didn't
share that screen i all right what's my email password um
give me a sec guys professional been streaming for at least
four years now It made me actually think longer.
I keep saying four years when the four years has passed
already.
All right.
Where's my password manager?
There you go.
All right, guys.
I need to get my email.
What?
What is...
Hello.
Where is my...
Oh.
Oh
All right, it got it went on my second monitor.
I don't like that.
It's not that I've tried too many times It's my first time
What do you mean I've tried too many times?
It's the first time I've logged in Oh, no guys, I don't
remember my email my password to my email.
That's not good.
What do you...
Okay.
Today is trying to remember my password day.
It has to be that.
What else could it be?
Would it be that?
No way.
When was the last time I updated my password?
I don't remember.
Okay.
It's not that.
Is it this?
could be this all right guys don't worry i'm figuring it out
oh no don't you hate it when like you might have changed
your password and then you don't know what it could be it
could be anything it actually could be anything
is it this I don't understand Okay, wait Wait, give me a sec
I got a My Microsoft account When was the last time I
changed my password?
I don't know Alright, my info Okay, where's the password
function?
Because I apparently I changed it recently And it's not
saved Okay Use my password, please.
This should be the password.
It is.
No, that's...
No, it's okay.
I don't need a pass key.
It is!
Okay, try...
Wait, actually, let me try again.
Okay, that is my password.
Why the fuck did it say it wasn't my password?
Okay, let me try this again.
Okay.
i signed it via the what oh i okay wait kv i'm doing capture
right now this is the capture stream there's no way that is
my password i literally just logged in to my hotmail with
that password how can it not be my password all right let me
try this again i'm gonna log into my hotmail again Maybe I
fucked up.
Maybe somehow.
Maybe I'm the one that fucked it up.
God, why is it linked to my...
I hate that it's linked to my Microsoft account.
Yeah, the last time I changed it was 2024.
So, like, that should be my password.
Okay, let me try it again.
Let me double check.
Yeah, I've been using Hotmail for a very long time.
Today is trying to see if I can remember my password day.
All right, I'm good.
What is...
Okay, I'm going to do a new password.
No, but then I have to...
Then it's going to sign me out of everything.
If I do that...
Enter password.
View active.
Sparta, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you,
I'm so excited to see you play my favorite series again My
screen name of almost 20 years is actually from my love for
the series not spark tank lol.
Thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you All right,
yes, okay.
I've just yes on safari A minute ago on wait a minute that
oh wait no Wait a minute.
Oh wait, no, that's that's me.
That's me.
I was like, oh Um, when did I sign in on Safari?
No, I have.
I have.
I was like, no, my phone.
I forgot about my phone.
Okay, wait.
I'll try an incognito mode to see if it that... Sorry, this
is the day of me trying to figure out my password.
Oh.
Because for some reason, Halo doesn't think that's the right
password, yet my email thinks it's right.
it's not my right i've you try to sign in too many times
with an incorrect account or password
oh my god am i locked up can i just not play halo now can i
did i try too many times i can't even
wait wait is that actually possible is that I don't want to
reset my password or I forgot my password you um all right
let me forget my password I guess
guys I might have to change my password I
All right.
No, I'm still signing in.
At least.
I'm still signing in on my Hotmail account.
All right.
I forgot it.
Don't worry.
We're going to play the game, guys.
We're going to play the game.
Complete.
Oh, yeah.
Get that code.
Okay, and I have to do my phone number.
Because they're like, We need to know if that's actually you
that forgot your password.
And I'm like, don't worry, it's me.
It's all happening on stream.
I'm not hacking somebody else's account on stream.
All right.
I have to do a new password.
I mean, fuck.
Okay, let me.
Let me, all right.
I have to do a new password now.
Don't worry.
This won't be hard.
All right.
password yeah okay password has been changed now I'm locked
out of everything now all right all
right that's fine okay I'm still actually I'm still locked
in apparently signing in the hotmail legendary difficulty
okay now all right verify or just text me It's easier.
I don't want to go through my email for this.
How do I must beat the robots?
Alright, guys.
Sorry.
Now I have to figure out.
Now I have to do capture, guys.
Alright, it's just one capture.
Thank God.
Okay, I'm human.
Come on.
Send me the capture code.
I've shown that.
Okay.
Marify.
Ah, we're in.
We're in.
Welcome back, Doki.
very thank you uh we're finally we're finally in town thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you i'm really
excited for you to experience my favorite game of all time
please enjoy the game that redefine what gaming is if they
came to hearing bag they will be disappointed oh message of
the day thank you all right let me put this on my first
monitor how the okay give me a sec i don't like that it is
not on the right monitor There we go.
What?
Set for all games.
Yes.
Hello?
It's still not on the right monitor.
I said set for all games.
Excuse me.
All right, that's fine.
That's fine.
It's fine.
All right, put the limit here.
Put my video settings.
uh at least there's no motion blur that's all i care about
all right set it for apparently when i boot it up it'll set
it for me so that's fine that's fine all right save settings
oh there we go yay oh oh where did my game go yay okay all
right guys are you ready for halo for real this time
real all right look at that we made it it was a journey this
was the hardest part of the entire game this was the hardest
part of out of everything i don't know sound guys here but
i'm gonna need you to help me with sound balancing soon also
i realize i forgot one thing since that this is a pew pew
game guys we did it we beat we got through the hard part
guys I'm so proud of us we we made it the hardest part of
this video game was to the real journey the hardest level of
all time whoops I forgot to whoops there was one thing I
forgot to do and was putting myself on the screen now on the
I assume it's quick start since I haven't played the game
yet.
Alright, was that played on Heroic last time?
Panzer, thank you for the magenta soup, thank you, thank
you, dokey, play Halo 2 on Legendary, and my life is yours.
Panzer, you want me on Legendary?
I'm sorry, but like...
You might...
Sorry, I'm...
Because it's the expense of my pain.
Yeah, my pain can be monetized, but it's like a universal
ticket.
It's like, so, oh, Halo 2 is not, what I thought.
I bought, okay, oh, that's awkward.
What do you mean, I have the whole collection, I have the
whole collection, but Halo 2, apparently.
apparently okay all right give me a second i'm buying halo 2
right now i thought i had halo 2 but apparently i did not
have halo 2 it's okay luckily i do have fiber so luckily
guys it's okay all right now now let me double check let me
double check my team i just literally bought it
Now, now I have Guys, don't worry Now I have Halo 2 I
There we go, let's go What?
Would you like to customize?
If you're in party, you will be disconnected Brockton, you
die, okay Alright Where is Where's Halo 2?
Is this Halo 2?
Yes, please Yes, please All right, there we go.
Now, 20 gigabucket!
All right, guys, let's...
My Kami Sekiro, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My Kamioshi.
Ginger, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, bro.
Patch and Reston, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
See you in 12 gigabytes.
Wings, thank you, the super chat, thank you, thank you, halo
appears on the screen, oh no, the meds are, guys, it's going
really fast, it's at 20%, it's only, it's fine, professional
streamer, by the way, let's just look at my options while we
do this, honestly, let's check if everything is fine in the
options category, I assume the voice balancing is like, the
same as any old game, where it does, it's not the greatest,
so how much is gonna cost me to playing Legendary Breezy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I heard Legendary is very, very, very, very hard.
So, so I might, I might need an Akka or two for that.
Silver, thank you, a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You don't play on Legend.
Just honor upon you.
This is my first time playing chat.
It's like, I can't just get into Legendary right off the
bat.
oh that kills me in 0.7 seconds yeah okay more than an akka
or two never mind guys it's more than just an akka or two if
like i get one shot by snipers and apparently it's not fun
it's
bet b thank you for the akka super thank you thank you
so legendary omni thank you Thank you for the Aka Super
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
Breezy, thank you for Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I was gonna ask to play on Legendary, but clear you're
already on Legend.
I'm trying to log into your account.
Guys, I told you this was the hardest level, so this is the
hardest level.
How could Legendary be harder than installing it?
I'm already playing on legendary mode.
Akoo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, let me double check all my settings.
Normal, normal.
I remember tab was where you swap graphics and everything.
All right, I think 240 is perfect then if I'm doing this
crazy shit.
Everything looks good.
Look at that.
90%.
We're almost there.
Okay.
All right All right, here we go.
Oh my god that husky.
Thank you for yonka soup.
Thank you.
I don't have fond memories of legend, but you should do it
anyway
Your enemies outnumber you greatly and are hunting you down.
Can you survive their onslaught?
How this I'll do one level on legendary can I swap
difficulties after chat can
I swap difficulties after I
need a no my chat froze the moment I asked that question I
guess I'll never know I is it's the I mean legendary like
thank you okay all right we'll try we'll try one level of
legendary and then we'll see we'll try what I just installed
it what do you mean pending oh I froze oh I I can't I'm not
even moving anymore I'm okay there all right there we go
pending am i it's not in oh i need a relaunch okay that
makes more sense i was like what do you mean pending i
freaking oh okay now my game is ready oh oh whoa whoa is it
oh sorry that was just that was an honest oh shit i it's all
over that was on oh it's okay it crashed the game crashed
It's all, it's all, it's everywhere to get, sorry, the game
crashed.
Here we, oh, bad.
All right, here we go.
Mr. Broken Bond, thank you.
We're lack of Supa.
They get the one level with LASO enabled.
They even lack of Supa.
They, everything is going so, it's okay, it's updating Halo
2 right now, guys.
It's updating Halo 2.
We're getting there, we're getting there.
We're making progress.
I told you.
I told you this is the hardest level, chat.
I did say this was the hardest level in the game.
It's getting Halo to work.
Don't worry.
We're almost there.
It's Amy Proust.
Okay, I'll do one level of legendary.
One level of legendary.
And then we're going back to heroic.
We're going back.
One level.
all right nine two percent we're almost there it's up it's
installing guys it had to do three different types of
installation all right i don't believe you
all right here we go putting up the game again i don't know
if it shows my email because I'm going to hide my game
screen just in case just in case
all right all right it's booting up it's taking its time oh
it was 93% completed whoops I put it up too soon I'll let it
finish it I was like oh 93% that's practically done killing
my PC, right?
It's actually killing my PC.
They're like not happy about this.
My PC's like, stop making stop!
Please!
Okay.
Oh.
All right.
Logging in.
All right, I need to tab out.
I need to tab out.
And then tap back in.
All right, here we go.
Everything looks okay.
All right, we're in.
Level one completed.
We did it, guys.
Breezy, thank you, the Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
You technically say you beat three levels on Legendary
because the first two are just...
Guys, guys, we did it!
First level on Legendary!
We fucking did it, guys.
It would be funny if I just clicked Heroic there because you
couldn't see the screen.
Oh, I'll never tell.
Are you sure?
Yes.
They called it the Pillar of Autumn.
What is that?
Ward, Ward, Ward.
Why was it not destroyed with the rest of their fleet?
flip as we set fire to their planet but I followed with all
the ships in my command when you first saw halo were you
blind by its majesty oh my god title drop dumbstruck no yet
the humans were able to evade your ships land on the sacred
word word and desecrated with their filthy footsteps noble
hierarchs surely you understand that once the parasite
attacked Speaking lies!
No, there's no way that's true.
But this demon, this master chief...
By the time I learned the demon's intent...
Oh my god.
Am I the bad guy?
Noble Prophet of Truth, this has gone on long enough.
Make an example of this bungler.
The council demands it.
You are one of our most treasured instruments.
your fleet with honor and distinction but your inability to
safeguard halo was a colossal failure i'm a demon
i will continue my campaign against the humans no you will
not what the wait that's not who's it who are these they
weren't part of the i didn't kill these before But when it
does, the weight of your heresy will stay your feet, and you
shall be left behind.
But he tried so hard!
It's not his fault.
Who can stop John Halo?
His name is literally Master Chief.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
There's viscosity throughout the gel layer.
Optics?
Totally fried.
And let's not even talk about the power supply.
You know how expensive this gear is, son?
Doki got alien Keith David thrown in a space jail.
Oh my god, he's talking!
That's me!
That's fucked up, Doki.
Didn't do anything.
I wasn't even there at the trial!
How is that on me?
If he would...
Maybe it was his fault for being bad at his job.
Your new suits of Mark 6 just came up from Songnam this
morning.
and take it easy until you get used to the upgrades all
right okay let's test your targeting first thing please look
at the top light good okay look at the bottom light all
right look at the top balancing is so bad already i could
tell the cut scene was so good and then the the in-game i'm
gonna run you through the full diagnostic the diagnostic
software sets your targeting system to be normal go ahead
and look at each of the four lights chief all right you want
me to leave it inverted i see normal i'll leave your
targeting set to normal if you change your mind you can
switch the setting anytime stand by i'm gonna offline the
inhibitor all right move around a little get a feel for it
when you're ready come meet me oh my god it's so different i
am not inverting guys I mean, it is brighter.
Oh,
that's so cool when you change it.
I'm only going over this once.
This station will test your recharging energy shields.
Step on in.
I'll show you.
Alright.
Your new armor shields are extremely resilient.
Very efficient.
Much better than the Covenant.
I don't know which one to use.
All right, guys, classic or...
Or...
Old, or new.
Where, I mean, this looks the same.
Bingo.
As you can see.
Classic?
All right.
We'll do classic.
If your shields go down, find some cover.
Wait for the meter to reach...
New?
Okay, we'll have a pull.
I'll do a pull real quick.
Here, Master Guns.
All right, guys.
I'll do a pull.
Wait, let me...
See if the settings are everything I need for this game.
See Halo 2, Field of View, HUD, original.
Alright, we'll do a pull, guys.
New for cutscenes.
Remaster is a bit bright.
I remember last time I used Classic and then I did...
Let's see.
Pull.
New or Classic graphics.
New.
classic all right guys it's up to you you guys have the
power sucks man it's literally unfinished using xbox
hardware constraints the lighting was gutted guys you give
this super chat thank you thank you
no but i want i would do want like a main focus for graphics
though um i'll do like i'll dip in and out i like classic
for gameplay and new for graph because i in the pat and in
the other one in the last playthrough uh when i can't see i
put on the new graphics because it's so fucking bright like
so i can see in the dark you are better all right a fresh
coat of netting lighting on the og is all right is
non-existent all right well nice i'm gonna stop here because
it ended at 69.
uh
So, so we'll go, we'll do a new graphics.
Nice.
69% mattered.
Yeah, he's like, the lighting's pretty ass on the classic.
Way to go, son.
Just remember, take things slow.
Don't worry.
I'll hold his hand.
Oh, it's him!
So, Johnson, when are you gonna tell me how you made it?
Johnson!
Yeah, how does he keep...
It's classified.
It's a clone.
Oh my god, he got promoted!
Sergeant Johnson!
Also, sound team, sound guide.
Let me know what the sounds are.
There's the goat!
I remember him because I kept getting him killed.
But he technically not killed because he's still alive.
Technically, he's still alive.
was all theory and politics now look like
that mac gun can put around clean through a covenant capital
ship whoa coordinated fire from the athens and the malta
nothing's getting past this battle oh i mean the classic
looks good for this part
oh yay i'm a hero Yeah!
Let's meet John Halo!
The dialogue volume is low.
I know.
That's like the worst part, I think.
Like, the sound balancing for these games are...
I mean, there wouldn't be any...
Told me you were gonna wear something nice.
Oh yeah, the new graphics are better.
So if you smile, what's that?
Well, we still got something to smile about.
What, what, what?
Where are these gorillas?
It must be like the new enemies.
He's just trying to do his job.
Drawn quite a crowd.
If they came to hear me beg, they will be disappointed.
Are you sure?
And then John Halo gets the party.
Cortana!
We have probes en route.
I apologize, but we're going to have to make this quick.
You look nice.
My chat GPT girlfriend.
Sergeant Major, the Colonial Cross is awarded for acts of
singular daring and devotion.
For a soldier of the United Earth Space Corps.
If I was such a bad guy and a demon, why do I get a medal?
Hmm?
Let him be an example for all who would break our covenant.
Oh,
shit.
Commander Miranda Keys.
Your father's actions were in keeping with the highest
traditions of military service.
His bravery.
Yeah, I know.
I said, if I was such a demon, then why do I get a meta?
The Navy has lost one of its best.
Holy shit, put the clothes back on him.
I do not like seeing him naked.
Okay.
Looks like a worm with limbs.
Yeah, censor that.
Oh my god, not safe for work.
Negative Admiral, form a defensive perimeter around the
cluster.
Commander get to your ship, link up with the fleet.
Use our word.
As soon as they come in range, open up.
Gladly.
Something's not right.
The fleet that destroyed Reach was 50 times this size.
Tokyo was sympathetic until she realized he was ugly.
No, until he realized, until I realized he was naked.
Yes, sir.
I need a weapon.
Right this way.
Oh, shit.
That's right.
I don't need an army.
You just need one Master Chief and that's it.
better late than never sir oh where's my weapon oh goodbye
oh down here i was gonna say where the fuck is my weapon is
that that should be my weapon that's a big ass gun they're
latched check your targets watch the crossfire oh god how
fast am i gonna die hello where is hello someone give me my
weapon hello wait i walked past the weapons locker oh i'm
sorry you guys are gonna die oh there we go got my weapon
all right don't worry i'm here now i'm here now guys don't
worry
oh god how fast am i gonna die oh god okay oh
all right i got my answer i got my answer there.
Wait, I can dual wield?
How?
I know I dual wield.
Alright, I got my answer on how fast I'll die.
That's good to know.
Holy shit, I already don't have armor.
For how much I hate this.
I gotta take cover.
Oh shit, I got reloaded.
It's okay, good thing I have I have a meat shield in front
of me.
Okay, got my meat shields.
Got cover fire.
Alright, now I can go through.
Okay, okay, never mind.
Never mind.
Holy shit.
I'll go back here.
I felt a lot safer over here.
Okay.
Oh, I don't have a lot of ammo left.
Can I even get on this?
No, I can't.
They're not swapped weapons?
Oh, here you go.
Oh, shit.
Dual wield.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Alright.
Spy.
I figured, is this faster to hold or, like, click?
The battle rifle.
What's the battle rifle?
There's a battle rifle?
Or did it miss?
Did I miss it?
Oh, is it this?
Wait.
Oh, it was on the wall?
But I like this gun.
I'll do a wheel this.
There you go.
The wheel.
Red on the wall.
This?
Oh!
Uh.
Okay, this is the best gun.
Alright.
A little but not too much.
Okay, yeah, I could do that.
See, like, how do I know what is the...
what is the voice for this it's not there's no different
settings oh yeah it wasn't like ah fuck okay I'm trying to
okay there's my leg oh I forgot the pistol is really good oh
well goodbye wait actually I can get the pistol again where
did I leave my pistol grab the pistol.
Okay, I'm going to use this because I can see better.
Because...
Oh, it's not in this one?
Okay, then that's good.
I can see better when it's on Classic.
I know where I'm going.
It's because the lighting is so ass.
Alright.
Wait, can I still...
Chief.
It was for science!
He lived!
He's still alive!
Remember, he's still alive!
Oh, God, I'm no.
Alright, I should be dead.
My new contact, I killed all of them.
Okay, now I killed all of them.
He's okay, guys.
He's okay.
Holy fuck.
Oh, my.
Oh, my God.
Recharge.
I would love to, but I'm on legendary right now.
I got a Jiggle Peak this.
I...
Holy shit.
Oh, fuck!
It's okay.
I have a checkpoint.
There you go.
I don't even know if dual wielding is good.
Find the border's point of entry.
Cut them off at the source.
Alright.
Jiko being successful.
Don't worry, he's still alive, right?
I can't...
Oh.
Wait, who shot him?
oh this wait who shot him this guy that guy literally took
half my hb
it's okay the interns got this oh never mind the interns
dead there's no way he's got me there's no way i
got his foot there you go we're okay
oh shit oh shit okay it's fine oh fuck it's okay i still
have my Okay, now I leave.
Now I stay here.
Oh!
Here we go.
I'll take my corners.
Alright.
I'm checking corners.
No flanks.
No flanking.
Alright, no flanks.
I don't think I have my melee binded.
I don't know what my melee is on this.
Oh, no.
I got my corners.
Oh, God.
I got to stay here.
I got my corners.
Oh, God.
That was one shot.
Alright.
It's Q by default.
Oh, shit.
What?
I don't know if melee is worth it.
If I throw my gun out.
Where did he go?
Oh, God.
Is he alive?
Oh, my God.
No, he's talking.
back
oh he flaked well now he flaked he crouched this is this
guerrilla tactics oh I see him wait no I think he's dead no
he stopped talking okay he's dead he's
dead okay oh my god where are the rest of the Marines
Okay.
Reload.
Okay, you're right.
I have to swap guns.
Where's his gun?
It's this one.
Alright.
Okay, I was just testing the ammo.
He's testing the ammo.
Alright.
Oh, I hear him.
I hear the...
Wait, he was not dead!
Oh god.
Oh that's a lot.
Oh it's way in front of me.
Oh
Okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
Everything is okay.
I'm jiggle peeking.
Oh god.
No, no!
They were everywhere.
I have to do this all over again.
Oh my god.
Oh my one level, Doki.
Just survive one level.
Just survive.
Just gotta survive one level, Doki.
Oh, yeah.
It feels like it.
It does feel like it.
Wait, is that him?
Okay.
Alright, both my Marines are still alive.
There's still hope, guys.
Both my Marines are still alive.
Oh god, oh god, oh god, don't come near me.
Where's my other gun?
Oh, I was reloading.
Okay, there is hope.
I have one more Marine.
Oh god!
Okay.
Okay, we're okay.
Bro!
Why?
Oh my god, he really doesn't Never mind, I understand I
understand What?
He was an asshole I can't see it What do you mean you can't
see it?
What are you shooting at?
I understand No, fuck that guy though Oh, it's this gun
Alright
Oh No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, oh,
that was close, that was close, that was close, that was
close, that was close,
oh, we're just gonna use one gun for now.
Because this is the fastest I can for killing people.
My trigger figure.
Where is he?
Oh, he's right there.
Where did he, fuck did he go?
Where did he go?
I know he's still alive.
Is he dead?
Did I kill him?
My radar doesn't tell me if there's people here or not.
Fucking.
knew it.
I fucking knew.
I knew you were so... Oh, shit!
You dead?
No, oh, he's just staring.
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck.
I hate that it's burned up.
Oh, I fucking knew it.
I knew you were playing dead.
Bam!
Fuck, okay, where's my gun?
Where did I put my gun?
I knew it.
I knew he was faking it.
There you go.
I think that hits him.
If I'm, like, up here?
Oh, fuck.
What hit?
Oh, shit.
Oh, I got the cover.
The bushes.
Fucking knew it.
Oh.
There's no way he's going to push up.
There's no way.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Please just gotta get through level one.
Get out of here!
Oh, she's dead.
He's dead.
Okay, I wasn't sure.
Alright.
Oh my god, we made it to checkpoint.
We're almost out of it.
You're on the first level.
I mean, who made you?
Surely it wasn't.
Surely it wasn't, right?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
I got a checkpoint.
Oh my god.
Heroic is going to be so easy after this.
Oh fuck.
Is he?
Okay.
This is...
Oh my god.
Oh, it's okay.
I have plenty of guns here.
I can just reload from here.
Alright.
just it's okay just slow and stay oh oh oh oh oh oh crap i'm
t-bagging i'm serpent serpentine i have no ammo my battle
rifle this is my battle rifle right wait there's my oh wait
this is my battle rifle okay
i got this Okay, I got this.
I got the corner.
I'll peek from the ladder.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, it's fine.
And they don't stop coming, and they don't stop.
Okay.
I know there's two more still alive in there.
Come on.
Okay.
Wait, wait, who shot me?
Who shot me?
Who the fuck shot me?
Oh my god, it's you.
It's fine.
I'm safe right back here.
Oh god.
I'll stay here.
Bro.
Oh, what the
fire?
It likes the pros and fives.
You can't take all of us.
And they're right.
They're so right.
They're like, you can't take all of us.
How did they know?
Oh my god.
It has the apex thing where if you take damage, I get
unscoped and I hate that.
there we go one down wait no he just moved he just moved
how much hp does he have
oh my god they regenerate shields they regenerate shields
when i'm regenerating oh my god oh my god i don't even know
when i'm fucking when i kill the shield they keep moving
behind walls
oh my god maybe i'll fight guys i need a five maybe i'll
find more battle rifle than i have okay
all right okay this is a little more difficult than i
expected this is a
okay i'm gonna go behind here oh There were frag grenades
right here.
All a lot.
What do you mean?
There were frag grenades here all a lot.
And why?
I was trying to throw my grenades.
Okay, we're back.
Guys, it is tactical because I wanted to get my ammo back.
I...
Okay.
There was grenades all alive.
How the fuck did I throw grenades?
What are...
What's the...
What's the control?
What's the control for grenades?
Because it's not G.
It's not G, guys.
It's F?
Okay.
Fuck this.
I have more.
where that come from boom
oh my god they're so smart now
fucking that's right get hot for me oh shit oh shit oh bob
and weave bob and weave oh fuck
there you go oh
boom i i don't have ammo anymore
It's okay.
Wait.
There we go.
Boom!
He's dead.
He can't hurt me.
Oh, God.
Alright.
Boom!
Oh, God.
I have to reload.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh, my God.
I'm trying to fucking get him.
Okay.
Are you fucking...
Oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh.
Oh, God.
Okay, but he can't get me from here, can he?
Ha, ha, ha.
He's so good.
Ha, ha.
He hit from me.
He actually hit.
He doesn't know I'm here.
Oh, my God.
I'm reloading.
don't recharge while i'm reloading
where is he wait he catches him oh shit
okay they knew i'm here oh my god i
oh no
oh no oh wait wait i have wait a minute this is bad Wait,
this is bad.
Maybe I can kill him.
Guys.
Okay.
Just survive the first level.
These days.
Alright.
That's okay.
I figured it out.
It's okay, guys.
Oh, fuck.
How long you're okay?
It's no longer okay.
I threw my other gun.
I actually threw my other gun.
It's no longer okay.
Everyone.
Okay.
There we go.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, these guys are insane.
Whoever these guys are, they do a lot.
Oh my god, and there's two of them.
I didn't even notice there were two of them.
Where was he?
Where was the one I was shooting at?
They're both white.
They're both white colored.
I don't even know which one was the one I was originally
shooting at.
They have dates too!
Oh
my god.
Oh my god, it's so over for me.
Getting on that plane.
I have.
Maybe.
Maybe they won't know.
Oh my god, you gotta be kidding me.
Oh my god, they're just Nate spamming me.
Oh my god, what do I do in that situation?
I keep accidentally throwing him away.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Oh, fuck!
I was tap farm everyone told me to charge it so I don't know
okay I wanted to get away from that run at first that was a
terrible run from me all right we're gonna I'm gonna fuck I
keep pressing FT equip instead because who fucking uses F
the grenade who I keep trying to Whip it!
This is bad.
Okay.
There we go.
I'll get both sides.
I'm playing around no more!
Get out of here!
That's right!
I'm playing no more!
Boom!
actually ultra instinct that oh i'm not i told you guys i
wasn't playing no more i was angry i i locked in i finally
locked i told you i ain't playing no more i that's fucking
right i jumped out i didn't know if i was supposed to oh
god wait there's more
Oh.
Okay, brace for impact.
Oh, there's more.
I shouldn't have jumped down.
I fucked up.
I didn't realize there was more.
I couldn't.
I couldn't see what's happening.
I just saw the ship docking.
I saw the ship docking.
Guys you can't expect me to pay attention to everything when
I'm fighting for my life right now.
I'm fighting for my fucking life at the moment, guys.
I'm fucking fighting for my fucking life.
I can't keep track.
Okay.
I mean, ha-ha.
There's this war.
Oh, God.
I was trying to Melee and...
No!
Okay.
It's okay.
I know what to do to staff.
I know what to do.
Okay.
Oh god.
Where's the last guy?
There are more boarding craft in your area, Chief.
Oh my god.
No.
It's going to be so easy after.
Oh my god.
I'm rebinding.
I cannot deal with this.
I cannot deal with F not being on F is grenade.
I really, it's actually, oh my, I swear to God, I'm going to
fucking freak out.
I keep doing that.
I'm rebinding everything.
I'm fucking fuck this.
okay and then f is equipped thank god all right here we go
now there we go now i won't keep accidentally there you go
that's much better
you're not recharging your shield on my watch if i have
anything to say about that
there you go
Oh shit, welcome to purgatory.
It really does feel like that.
You're not hiding from me.
Oh god, oh god.
Oh god.
I have to recharge too.
Come on, just get rid of his shields.
Come on!
We're nades here.
Are you fucking- I hate that!
Is there a way to turn it off that doesn't unscope after?
That's like the worst part about it- about it.
That it unscopes if I get hit.
No?
I don't like that.
It's like Apex.
God damn, at least I got him.
I'm dead though.
I have to stop taking damage.
I'm stuck in hell.
I can't just stop taking damage.
Oh, my God.
I ran out.
I assumed I was hitting him.
Just don't get hit.
It's just that easy.
All right, let me...
All right, let me grab this.
and then grab this and then grab that and then start
spamming and then and then turn this oh
god i forgot the timing
this this is hell i think i'll just be trapped in this
purgatory the entire time oh my god thank god it's just one
air i'm just i i i'm see it i'm fucking digressing as a
player.
Oh my god.
Just survive this level and everything will be so easy.
Just survive this level.
And then everything will be a fucking walk in the park.
Like literally right after I just... Oh, I just killed my
own men.
And then everything will just be so easy.
It will be so easy.
Oh my god, I don't have the grenade right off, I forgot.
I'd fucking just do it on myself.
Just survive this area, Doki.
Just survive level one.
Just level one!
Level one!
Survive level 1 Just survive level 1 Oh god there's so many
There's so many of them Survive level 1
This one I was shooting at you
Where did he go?
Where was the guy I was stuck?
No, I'm going straight back to Heroic right after guys.
You guys are not getting legendary right after that.
You guys are not getting legendary right after this.
This is the only time you'll ever see legendary from me.
For the first time player.
The thing is, I am...
You got to be like, oh my god, she didn't see this.
I'm fighting for my fucking life.
I can't see anything that's going on.
All I can do is shoot.
She's missing this important scene.
And I'm out here in the fucking war right now.
I can't.
I'm out here in the fucking goddamn war.
We ain't catching anything that's going on to the plot
anymore.
We're...
I just hope to live.
The plot is that I hope I can be alive.
Alert.
That's the plot God I hope she lives I'm literally on the
front lines
No, if someone tells me to try LASO I don't know what the
fuck that is But judging from my experience doing this right
now It's not even a thousand It'll be 5k 5k for my suffering
But
I need to go back for nades.
I ran out.
Oh, a fucking course he nades me.
Oh, and that...
The one needle.
The one fucking needle.
There we go.
I can't recreate some time.
I locked it in.
I cannot.
That's the worst part.
The fact that I can't recreate the moment when I truly
locked in.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I have to actually.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh my god, there's two of them.
I forgot about that.
I forgot there's two of them.
I forgot that there's two of them.
And now I have no ammo.
Now I have no ammo.
Now, fuck.
Yeah.
Guys, I would love to be able to stick them with nades.
That would be my dream.
But unfortunately, my dream might be dead.
Blades.
He has blades.
Ah!
Fucking baby is.
He has the blade.
No, I can barely.
see in classic i i see better over here at
the sword how did you miss it because i forgot i binded into
this all
right you
know that was the whole point
fuck there you go i got it
and you have focus on that guy but particular
him him no
I had to kill him okay oh
god there's more coming in and I don't have nades I oh my
god yeah
you fucker you actual fucker
God, you take up a goddamn stupid grunt!
Where's the other one?
Where's the other grunt?
Where is he?
Where is he spamming goddamn stupid needles?
And a grenade too?
I fell down.
I fucking fell down.
Alright, it doesn't matter.
Oh my god, this is...
This was a 1v1, sir.
This was a fucking 1v1.
Sir, let me have my 1v1.
Fuck you.
Actually, fuck you.
Oh my god.
Fuck me, too, I guess.
You can't hide from all these needs.
You can't hide from...
He's dead.
That's fine.
That was worth all the nades.
That was worth it.
It was worth all the nades.
It was worth it.
I'm staying up here.
I'm not going back down.
Oh, yeah.
Now I can watch the cutscene, guys.
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
after all there you go there we go guys i get to watch the
cutscene holy shit oh my god wait we did it i can see this
now i oh my god oh
i did it i get to see how beautiful that was i i got my
checkpoint oh my god it doesn't matter what happens to me
now all right give me your fucking gun okay now I have to
rebind us because I keep pressing E now I keep pressing E
instead of F or is it E I did I beat Alo too, guys.
Guys, I did it.
That's a win.
I beat Alo too.
That's fine.
I have a checkpoint.
Nothing matters to me anymore.
I can't see.
I'm gonna turn it here.
I fucked this.
This guy, they should not have that much ammo.
Or they should not have that much heals.
what that's very awkward for me it's very awkward for me
he shot my feet he shot my feet
that's it
what the fuck he's jiggle peeking me
oh god but like what if we like, should you go pick each
other?
No!
That's okay.
I got the checkpoint.
I get to see the scene.
Nothing matters.
Nothing matters to me.
I got the checkpoint, so nothing matters anymore.
Oh, I can't shoot through railings.
It'll be funny if I can, though, you know?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
It's fine.
I know I have another gun here.
There we go.
I lost the Jingo Peak fight.
I'll stay up here this time.
You should be dead.
There we go.
Nice.
See?
Yeah, I know plasma is better for Shias, but like...
But like...
Can't be bothered right now.
I just have to go, I have to go down here and grab a gun.
All right, there you go.
I make sure there's ammo in that one.
Oh, it's like different songs, too.
I can see better here, so I'm going to be played.
Oh, shit, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, it was trigger fingers.
Oh, man.
New contact.
Okay, now I can see better here.
I hope I'm shooting him.
It's working, though.
This strat is working for me, so I'll keep doing it.
I
think I'm hitting him.
I...
All right, the peekaboo strat.
If that's what I have to do, that's what I have to do to get
through this area.
Oh, God, I have to go back.
There we go.
Oh, God.
I actually can't peek.
What do you mean you got it?
Where is that coming from?
Alright.
Oh, I think my Marines are dead.
Oh, they are.
Fuck this.
Oh, shit.
No longer.
Fuck this.
Wait, unless...
Do I have more ammo in my... Nope.
I mean, them dying was actually very helpful for me.
because I needed...
It's okay.
Alright, it's fine.
I have my strat.
Oh, shit.
I forgot about the turret, guys.
I had my strat, but then...
But then I forgot about my turret, guys.
There must be a... I'm getting on that turret.
I'm getting on that fucking turret.
Oh, shit.
No!
I'm getting out of that turret.
No, get off the turret!
Get off the turret!
John Hale!
What the fuck did he explode?
Get off the turret!
Yes, I know that was a shield, but I mean...
no oh god no no
oh god oh god they're all coming
oh god they're all they're all silently approaching me it's
okay
he must be low i threw so many days over there
are you kidding no
all right it's Yeah, get on the turret again.
We're almost there.
We're almost out of level one.
Surely we're almost out of level one.
God, this game is going to be so fucking easy right after.
This game is going to be so easy right after.
I can feel it.
It's going to be so easy after.
levels after when we're back to heroic i can feel how easy
it's gonna get
okay at least these guys don't have shields so i'm just
trying to get rid of the little yeah and you're not hiding
behind that for me oh oh all right wait how long have i been
streaming for
How long has it been?
Why is she dual wielding?
Because I don't have a gun up here.
I don't have a gun up here, guys.
I should have asked for more.
Wait, is this...
oh my god battle rifle now it was a door here
i got scammed but the dragoons got me oh my god do you see
the army over there i i don't even want to fucking i'm just
gonna sit here i i
hate that like okay i got the little guys.
I don't know what.
I'm just trying to grab the little guys out.
You guys say that, but it doesn't feel like it.
The energy gun does not feel like it does, like, they have
so much shield.
It feels like I'm still just tickling them.
Even though I use this, it just feels like I'm tickling
them.
It's like, t-t-t-t.
Like,
I thought I already got rid of their shield.
So I went for it.
Oh, I threw it at myself.
That was my last name.
Silly me.
I got caught.
I got caught in the fight.
I was trying to grab the fucking name.
Oh.
I'm gonna let them die.
Because I need that high ground.
I need this high ground.
Wait, actually, I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna grab the battle rifle.
Where's the battle rifle?
There it is.
Alright, now I have ammo for this.
And I'm just gonna take out the little guys.
And then I'll think about the big guys at a later point.
Where's the little one?
There we go.
Alright, now let me figure out how to deal with these guys.
This guy.
This guy got hit by all of it, right?
You shouldn't have armor here, right?
Apparently he does still have armor.
Not him, though.
Nope, he still has a lot.
he have so much ammo how does he have so much army oh my god
oh my god man thank you for the raid i'm going through my
own personal nine circle of hell right now i'm going through
my nine circle it's okay it's just nine apparently there's
there's deeper in levels
oh my god go up canton shoot him anymore.
Oh, look at him.
He's so happy.
The second wave.
I forgot the second wave existed.
That one.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Surely after this, I... Surely after this level one ends,
right?
Right guys?
Okay, where the fuck is this other man's nade?
It's fine.
And I'll take high ground here.
And then after that.
This is the last part of level one, right?
This entire stream is just one level I have, you know.
Oh my god, they're just chilling over there.
They're just chilling.
They're actually just chilling over there.
Man, I wish I had 500 nades.
I wish I didn't use my 80 nades earlier.
That's awkward.
Maybe he has more.
Alright,
maybe...
Okay.
Oh, they're just chilling there.
I think it's over for me.
Okay.
uh there's peekaboo right here
yeah i
can't see them and then i started blasting oh my god the
reload takes 80 years too i think that's the worst part
i hate that i take 20 years to reload
oh my god oh my god ending aid okay yeah fuck me i guess all
right just I don't get anything in life I where am I wait
there's a down okay the downstairs lead to nothing
I need to start meleeing
all right oh
my god guys I think it's over for me guys this doesn't look
too good for
Let me show you how fast I can do this level.
Wait, can I even swap difficulties midway?
Can I do that?
Halo 2.
Where the fuck is the difficulty swap?
Where the...
I can't even swap.
Okay.
I still have ammo.
Oh my god, I don't even know.
Oh my god, I forgot they exist I've been stuck in that area
for so long I forgot the turret guys existed
That's how long I've been stuck in this purgatory
That's how long I've been stuck in my second But the tenth
circle of hell I was in the ninth circle of hell And they're
like, here's the tenth one
Oh my god, I forgot I don't have ammo for this
Alright, classic time Alright, no longer classic time I
can't see shit
Oh my god, these guys These guys
Yeah Wait, he's dead Wait, oh fuck
I forgot about the other guy Again
Okay, I might be able to kill him Without having to Never
mind Never mind
Okay Wait, I have a charge I have a charge right here
Where did I throw the charge gun?
Oh my god, it's right here I can't even get on the turret,
even if I want to.
Even if I really, really want to.
I can't even.
Oh my god, I don't even have a charge one.
Let me stay in this pit to die.
Who's shooting me?
I don't even know which one's the plasma pistol.
I can't, I don't even have time to register the guns.
right now, but the front lines never played Halo 2 before,
and I'm already fucking dropped in the middle of the front
lines of war.
The green one.
There's a green gun.
I can't even register colors.
I'm just at war.
I'm literally just at non-stop war.
I can't even register what the colors are.
Oh my god, he's holding the plasma gun.
That's it.
I'm backtracking.
I'm grabbing a different gun.
Wait, there you go.
Plasma, path pistol.
There you go.
Oh my god, you're so low.
Oh my god, everyone's shooting me now.
Wait, okay, it doesn't matter.
Yeah, I'm just gonna...
Oh my god.
the little guy is still alive this is not fair this is oh my
god he's fucking holding his knife out as he's like i'm
gonna get you and he is
here you go
oh my god
okay please look come closer No!
Oh my god, forgot about this.
Okay, I need the green gun.
Okay, we're gonna grab, get rid of, oh my god.
I'm gonna go get rid of the little guys first.
We're gonna get rid of the little guys.
Okay.
Oh my god, I got the combo!
I got it!
Oh god.
Oh my!
Okay, I got it, guys, guys.
I got the system.
I got this.
I'm learning.
Okay.
Alright.
I figured it out.
What does this mean?
I will continue playing?
No.
Fuck no.
no fuck legendary actually fuck legendary why would anyone
do this to themselves oh my god he just dodged it he
literally just dodged it okay i need to know if i can scroll
wheel i'm gonna scroll i can't fucking press numbers right
now i i can't press numbers right now where's the oh my okay
what where's one change weapon i'm fucking there you go i
can't be fucking pressing numbers at the moment
what did it hit anybody i jacked up
okay all right
he has to reload okay apparently not
who did i Hit!
Who did I hit?
Who did I even hit?
Who did I?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Um, I don't have this no more.
Oh, that's so awkward.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna go backtrack and get another gun.
I'll be back, guys.
Guys, don't worry.
I'll be back.
Okay.
surely there's another one who has this gun surely oh yeah
they all okay wait nice alright there we go I'm back I'm
nope we still got another one still got another one I like
that they waited patiently for me I really appreciate that
I don't know even know which one I hit.
I don't even know.
Fuck.
I'm trying to find the grunt.
I'm trying to kill the grunt here.
The little guys before I go for the big guys.
I think they're all big guys now.
No.
Okay.
Yeah.
Unlucky.
Oh.
Oh, there you are, big boy.
There you are.
I was wondering if you were gonna show up.
Oh my god.
I threw it on myself.
I threw my one plasma grenade on myself.
I'm gonna wait until they all group up.
I'm just gonna wait until they all group up.
Oh, he saw me.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
I'll wait here.
You guys are group up for me?
Oh, and then they all just...
The all just...
Roll away!
Oh, they all just rolled away!
Can't make this up.
You can't make this up!
You can't...
The shield spawned back!
The shield actually spawned back!
that's crazy that's like crazy that the shield has spawned
all right guys give me a sec i'm gonna i'm gonna go find
another gun i'll be back guys i'll be back
surely there's another gun that i left truly i've left If I
left one, there could be another gun, guys.
You gotta keep hoping.
Because hope is all I have left.
Oh, see, guys?
I told you.
Eight shots.
It's okay.
I still have one more.
I might be able to kill one more guy.
there we go oh my god he's coming for me isn't he he's
coming for me isn't he oh my god i should start looking back
at him all right sure he's coming over it's just that he's
coming
all right so we do have an issue now we
might have okay wait It's time.
It's time.
It's now..
It's now alien- Oh!
Okay!
Okay we can do this- It's okay, we figured it out.
We figured out the strat!
All right.
Kill me.
I forgot about the turrets.
I forgot about the turrets again.
I- I- Oh!
because you don't understand after when you're stuck in that
area for so long you always forget about the turrets oh my
god I forgot no ammo in this gun I'm
I it's fine I'll just kill the grunts I'm just gonna kill
the grunts first it's fine it's fine it's not fine but it's
fine It's not fine, but like, there's what else can I...
There's nothing else I can do.
Yeah.
Get rid of the little guys first.
Just get rid of the little guys first.
Oh my god, the big guy shielded the little guy, that whore.
That fucking whore.
Okay.
It was in fact not fine anymore, guys.
but okay
being in this corridor helps the most because they all line
up oh my god oh my god they put the little babies in the
front the moment i fucking pulled it up because the course
they did
no oh my god please tell me i got him though please tell me
i got him he stood right in front of me
No, come on, are you serious?
Oh, what plasma grenades?
I know, right?
No plasma grenades.
Okay, we got one.
We got two.
We go grab.
We got the plasma.
We grab this.
We shoot the little guys.
Okay, we try to shoot the little guys.
If they fucking look at me.
Okay, one little guy down.
Our two big guys down.
I don't know if that actually hit him, though.
I don't know if that actually hit him.
Where's the little guys?
Oh, there he is.
Okay, we just gotta get rid of the little guys.
okay thank god okay we got him before the big ship comes in
okay i know i know he had a plasma he had two that's good
that is good
oh there's a little guy there was a little guy
all right they're confused okay
that's fine that's fine
in a little corridor now.
They have to look at me.
There we go.
We're okay.
We got a system down.
We have a system in place.
Okay, wait.
I'll get rid of the little guy first.
Okay.
Get out of that shield.
Come on.
Oh my god.
Alright.
I did not expect them all.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay.
Alright, I'm just gonna chill right here real quick.
Alright.
We have a system down.
There we go.
System down.
To the T.
Okay, we got them out.
We got him out.
We got a knife boy out.
We got...
It's okay.
I know there's one more plasma gun back here.
With one shot.
One shot is better than no shot.
I'm starting to believe.
I'm starting to believe, guys.
Oh my god.
Okay.
All right.
Wait, it's more than one shot.
It's 60 not nice.
Oh my god, did I kill him?
I don't know.
Oh, that was so close.
That was so close.
Come on, peek me.
Come on.
I'm in the corridor.
Get closer.
Come on, you know you want to.
You know you want to get closer.
come on that's right alright two more shots and there's two
more guys
is it over is it is it over hey they're leaving the Athens
is it is it over yeah oh god oh shit Okay, that's another
explosion Oh my god, I did it.
I fucking did it
It's over it's fucking over castle out loud I've been
streaming that's how I told me to figure out the combo
Another ship God
It's so it's the sword worth it chat is it is it worth it?
Is it worth it guys?
Is it?
Is the sword worth it?
I'd never be able to unlegitary.
Should have had... Now I know I'll never make this mistake
again.
I should have asked for more.
It's not for you.
Alright.
Alright, that's all I needed here.
That's not all I needed here, guys.
That's all I needed here.
I don't even know if it's worth dual wielding.
I don't think it's worth dual wielding, guys, with what I
have to go through.
Wait, unless...
Unless it's dual wielding this gun, maybe?
Okay, I think it's worth it if it's dual wielding this gun.
It's probably...
Not on legendary?
Okay.
oh my god i don't even know where to go i'm just so happy i
got through this area i i just i don't know what the next
step oh it's down here okay
and then
what oh
my god i don't even know oh my god oh my god i'm sorry
go.
That hit him, though.
That hit him.
Okay, it's fine.
Wait.
Hit the wall?
Oh, hit the wall.
Wait, guys.
Did I even get a checkpoint?
Did I, did I even, guys, did I even get it?
Guys, did I, did I get a checkpoint, guys?
Guys, give it to me straight.
Did I, did they give me?
No way.
There's no way.
Oh.
How do I swap from plasma to my regular, to grenade, regular
grenade to plasma?
It feels like it doesn't do that.
Oh, it didn't pop up.
Oh, checkpoint!
I got...
There it is.
There.
Oh, is it too?
Okay, there we go.
But now I can actually use my grenade.
Okay, there's the checkpoint.
And there's the checkpoint.
There it is.
Oh.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh my god, there's another checkpoint.
There's another checkpoint.
Come on now.
Is that a weapon or a procure?
Oh, I don't think he lived.
He doesn't, he won't expect me from here.
Oh my god.
Oh my god,
another checkpoint.
Oh my god, it's fine.
Okay, you got the headshot.
Oh.
This ethereal shit's out.
There's no way that guy threw a fucking raid at me.
There's no fucking way.
Okay.
He dodged it!
Oh,
wait, I don't have ammo on this gun.
Wait a minute.
He died pretty far.
This is bad.
I'm booking it.
Oh, God.
It's five.
He's not gonna expect it twice!
There we go.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Okay, we're making it.
We're making it.
Got another plasma pistol.
No.
Are you...
fucking kidding me
okay we're five oh my god i hit the fucking wall it's okay
it's so everything is fine everything is fine
nice there
you go
it's fine i have a where is that little guy i know you exist
There's the little guy.
Oh, did I kill him?
Wait.
Get me up here.
I want to be up here.
Okay.
Must be another pistol I can grab.
There you go.
A hundred bullets.
Okay.
We're cruising through.
Oh!
There you go.
We're cruising.
through we're cruising through it now all right now that
we've realized the combo we're slowly but surely sure slowly
but surely we're making our way through
oh my god
i must have killed something right okay He's gonna peek.
He has to peek.
He have to.
Come on.
You know you want to come over?
Oh, God.
Now he peeks.
A fucking course he peeks now.
A fucking course you peek now.
You fucking...
There we go.
We got it.
Check your course.
always check your corners, guys.
Always check your fucking corners.
Always check your goddamn corners!
Anyone down here?
Alright.
That's where they get you.
That's where they fucking get you.
Where couldn't they get me from here?
Oh.
Oh my god, Johnson!
If I can count on anybody, I can count on Johnson!
Johnson, I'm coming over!
Thanks, Chief.
Oh my god, we made it.
The unkillable.
Okay.
Got another fully-kitted plasma gun.
Charging it up right now.
Where am I?
Wait.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're back here.
We're back here.
Thanks, Chief.
Alright.
I'll let them go in first.
You first, Sergeant Johnson.
You're unkillable.
If I know anything, you can't die.
Don't let up, sir.
Wait, that's not Sergeant Johnson.
Wait, we're Sergeant Johnson.
Oh, Sergeant Johnson, if I know anything, you can't die.
I'm sorry, they were both wearing a white uniform.
Oh, Sergeant Johnson, come on, bro.
Why are you so scared for it?
Why are you so scared for your sergeant?
All right, you go.
It's okay, Sergeant Johnson can't die.
Oh, and then the extra BM.
Yeah, fuck that guy.
No, I agree, though.
I agree.
Fuck that one alien in particular.
Hey, wait, where did y'all go?
Oh, this way.
Hey, guys.
Don't you guys want to keep going?
Guys?
Come on, guys.
don't you guys want to keep going with me I can see here
though why are they jumping wait a minute why are they
jumping guys wait a minute oh wait a minute oh my god you
fucking kidding me now they can fly now they can fly Oh my
god, now I have to shoot them in space.
I have to shoot them in space now.
Okay, alright, it's a space fight.
Oh my god, now it's zero gravity time.
Oh, we're fucking in space.
They can't hear me scream.
They can't hear me cry.
Oh my god, now they fly.
Borders have reached the fire control center.
They have a bomb.
Can you defuse it?
Yes, but I'll need the chief's help to make contact with the
debt leader.
Chief, get to the bomb.
Double time.
Cortana, prioritize targets and fire at will.
Cortana, please.
Can you just fire at all of them?
Oh my god, they're actually just flying away.
Wait, they're actually just flying away.
Maybe he'll hit his toes.
Oh, thank god it hit his toes.
I got his toes, though.
Don't worry.
Toes got
Wait, I got him up.
There you go.
It's fine
Okay, checkpoint done If I have to I will kill you for ammo
I'm going loud
Oh, okay, never mind.
I did it too soon.
Already coming back up.
Oh, they're triggered by me.
Oh!
What the fuck is this?
Oh my god, this is actually bullshit.
Oh my god.
How do I kill?
How do I kill that?
Okay, they don't have shields.
they don't have shields
oh my god but do are they weak do they have weak points with
bullets of course okie silly okie I just shoot him
where's the head where is it I just see all body ok
oh my god and they fly too
oh my god and they're on walls oh my god they're they're
also on walls
oh god get me out of here get me out of here get me out of
here give me out of here
okay oh my god and they fly it's like a fucking fly swatter
right now
oh boy at least it's it is satisfying oh i see you it is
satisfying to see them fall into their fucking depths into
the pit of despair i feel like there should have been more
people defending this fucking space tower
oh i'm like fly swatting right now but with bullets
At least I can swap my gun out
Everything good to go Why do I even say anything?
Why do I even Attempt to say anything
What do you mean elevator fight time?
I can barely fucking lift Fighting them one by one
Okay, I can see them better here.
I'm going to use this graphics.
So this doesn't...
That hurts me!
I got stuck.
Okay.
We're fine here.
Oh, goodbye.
We'll come back down, right?
It doesn't come back down.
Oh my god.
okay that's fine that is fine get on the elevator okay i got
on just in time goodbye elevator oh god oh god
all right are we okay are we okay okay now okay checkpoints
done oh at least they'll hit someone oh it didn't hit
anybody oh i have no cover for this oh my god i can barely
even oh my god
okay the first carrier completely ignored us that's fine
i'll even i'll just force this guy off of the high ground
there you go it's fine it's fine i have 108 bullets i had
108 bullets okay things seem to be going okay right now guys
i need you guys to give me a recap on what's happening on
level on the first level i my brain is just full on war is
on survival mode.
I'm not absorbing anything right now.
I need you guys to be painfully aware that I am not
absorbing anything lore-wise.
I...
I'm just...
I'm just trying to survive.
I'm... I know I'm trying to...
I'm trying to kill the aliens from the space station, but I
do not know what else is going on.
Oh, there's a Bomb?
Guys, I told you guys I didn't even realize there's a bomb
on the spaceship.
All I fucking know is that I have to live, which might not
be gonna, which might not work very well right now.
Which might not be happening.
Oh, please tell me there's another fucking plasma pistol
here.
Here.
Just a small bomb.
There we go.
Where's the other one?
I know there's another alien.
Oh my god, he's over there, isn't he?
Okay.
All right.
Okay, they're both dead.
Wait, do I have another plasma?
pistol here no they're both the red they're both the elites
okay now I'm in the pit oh quite a few elites oh just a few
you know what I'll take a few Cortana Cortana you don't I've
been I've only been fighting elites Cortana
that's all I've been fighting
It's only elites!
Okay, I'm gonna...
Oh my god!
Let's find you!
Kratata, please!
I'm so tired!
I'm so tired, Kratata!
Oh my god!
Oh my
god, fucking Corzy, he gets the needle.
Oh, he's dead.
He's dead.
Where did he come from?
Alright.
I didn't even realize there was another entrance.
I will be perfectly honest with you guys.
I didn't realize there was an area here.
There was a hole here.
Oh my god, I have to reload.
Please tell me I got the guy that was trying to kill me
earlier.
I mean, that's a lot easier knowing that I have another
entrance here.
Oh.
I missed.
Okay.
Now I don't have any more.
What the?
Oh.
What?
It might hit something.
Anything.
Oh my god, it did.
It actually did.
I didn't, honestly, I did not think that would actually hit
anything, but I will take those.
Oh.
It's okay.
I do have more plasma grenades.
Minus is pushing me away.
Oh, shit.
What?
Where did he come from?
Wait.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Okay, I did not see that guy behind me.
I got him.
Okay, I have one more bullet.
bullet in a dream.
Got him.
Alright, guys.
I wish I had more fucking plasma.
I can't believe I keep forgetting to reload on that area.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't.
Just kill me.
Just kill me with your stupid needles.
Just do it.
Every kill matters.
okay reload
here we go reload every kill matters
am I
no I know it's a motion sensor but I'm like fucking I have
to keep track of 800 things at once are you fucking okay
it's dead he's dead dead he's dead well now i know now i
know
oh my god it didn't track him i thought it would track i
thought it would track it
oh my god it wasn't even the one i wanted to okay it's fine
let's get me back in here you won't know there's no way
Okay, I legitimately thought.
Okay, that should kill his shields, though, right?
He takes the full hit, and it's okay.
Oh.
Please, please.
No!
I got
you!
That's fair.
I don't know who that shot.
Okay, that got him.
I have one more shot.
regen though oh
no i might be stuck in the corner again
okay oh
god oh god
it's not here where is he that's so true where did he go
i'm gonna see if i can break his shield i'm here fucking i
can't
No!
He rolled away!
Oh my gosh.
I got three left.
Three.
I can't believe he rolled away.
I don't even know.
I don't even know who I shot anybody.
I don't even know if I shot anyone.
I think I got him.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I got him.
Okay, that's five.
That has to kill him.
There's no way.
There's no way that doesn't kill him.
Oh, my God.
There actually is no way.
That he asked.
He left.
Oh, my God.
One got flinked.
And then I got...
Oh, okay.
Okay, fuck you.
All right, that's it.
That's it.
I'm locking in.
The extra BM too.
That's it.
I'm locking in.
I can't.
Not locking in for this one, though.
Not for this.
Oh, man.
I need to reload this.
Okay.
so one more shot
I don't know which one that's gonna kill
okay I gotta make sure I don't get crushed
they're gonna be kidding me the slope you can't climb up the
slope you can't climb up the fucking slope and try to climb
up okay all right all
right now we swap I
thought I got it
okay there you go
oh god
damn it I thought that would hit him I really did I'm
spamming it up I don't care I'm spamming it up oh my Oh my
god, are you fucking...
Oh my god, they're both needleers too.
They're both needle guns!
Okay.
No, no, no!
Okay, I might have to...
And just hope for the best.
And then just hope for the best.
Oh my god, I'm not hoping for the best anymore.
Oh,
my God, that, my first mistake.
God, does he know where I am?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
No, no.
He's been looking at them.
I can't get it.
The dealer is so far.
It's literally so far.
It's so far from me!
How do I get something that's so far?
Oh, God.
Wait.
I don't have...
Oh.
Wait.
I do have needs.
Oh, my God.
Are you serious?
I just think I'm here.
Oh!
I think I killed him.
I think I killed Red.
Oh my god, to reload.
Oh my god, I don't know how to kill this guy.
I don't know.
I can't.
I can't risk it.
Oh, oh god.
Oh my god.
How do I kill him?
His shield is down.
I didn't even need no.
Okay, I got the needle.
Oh Oh God, oh God, oh God, okay
You both both okay, all right, I'm panicking I'm trying All
right, here we go I'm flanking him
Yeah Inside your head now
How much time was left?
How much time was left as long as father?
Like, take your time, Doki.
Take your fucking puppy.
Not against a ship that size.
Not on your own.
Sir, permission to leave the station.
For what purpose, Master Chief?
We did it, guys.
We beat Adelaide.
Just in time, guys.
I can't believe it.
We stopped the bomb.
Oh
He got the mid-level And it's crazy I didn't even realize I
was trying to stop the bomb until I asked I was like I can't
cop I can't digest anything in this game.
I just want to live.
I just want to survive
just one question what if you miss I won't oh damn he's like
how dare you say think I'll miss I never miss holy shit what
yeah you think I a I won't be so That's why he's my goat.
Holy
shit.
Oh.
Package returned.
Return to sender.
Oh my god.
He's so fucking cool.
No wonder he's called a demon.
Oh.
Millions are dead.
But it was the enemy.
So that's alright.
We did it.
We beat.
We did it, guys.
We beat Halo 2.
Oh, yeah, King.
Guys, we did it, guys.
We beat Halo 2.
It just took three hours.
Three hours.
The message just repeats.
Regret.
regret catching any idea what it means dear humanity we
regret being alien bastards we regret coming to earth and we
most definitely regret the core just blew off our raggedy
ass fleet nice in the words of my favorite quote from
earthbound it was a good experience let's never do that
again omni thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you it
only took me an hour and a half to figure out the combo
Hoorah!
We're going in.
Get tactical Marines!
Master Chief, get aboard that carrier, secure the profit of
regret.
This is the only place on earth the Covenant decided to
land.
Oh wait, that was only level one?
So it's like, wait, what?
What do you mean?
That's only level one.
Yeah.
Blinky if you can hear me, Chief.
Shake it off, Marines.
Clear the crash site.
Go, go, go!
I don't...
Which one did I do just now?
I've
been...
It's like...
Swap back.
Oh, it's so legit.
give me a sec i didn't realize when i click resume it'll
take me back it'll take me back blink if you i was like
where was i i was so confused i'm asking once again i i'm
raising my price i realized i definitely got stabbed i Thank
you for the Akka super.
Thank you, thank you.
I realized I got scammed.
I thought I would like 10 Akkas.
Not one or two.
I would like 10 Akkas.
Not...
All right, here we go.
You will use...
Yes, please continue.
Did not get scammed.
I got scammed.
That's right.
I'm upselling now.
I don't get no area.
Jaker's for the office.
But I have a goal.
I forgot there was a thing for this.
Give me a sec.
I remember there was way to do this where was it it was like
oh here we go here we go wait did they remove it guys
remember that funny thing where they you could like oh i
think they removed it there was like you could start oh it's
this oh they removed it there was like a gold thing you can
do it was like a hype tree they actually took it out and
then put on um There was like, yeah, it was a thing you were
able to do where it was like the Twitch's hype train where
you can...
Wait, or is it... Do I do it like here?
Yeah, they actually... They took it out!
It doesn't exist no more.
They actually... Please continue to enjoy the game in the...
in the road.
It's not even worth a thousand.
What do you mean?
Yeah, it's gone now.
All right.
One is against.
Okay, here we go.
All right.
All right, 15.
Oh, my God.
Here we go.
Hello, I'm back here.
I'm back here.
Hey now.
Oh, God.
Whoops.
A tab out accidentally.
What happened?
I actually stabbed him!
Oh, let's hope that nobody comes over after I shot the guy.
Okay, hurry up, hurry up.
I've been through so much.
Just in case, just in case, I'll bring a plasma gun with me.
Just in case, I have to go through this.
Oh my god, this game definitely feels...
Okay.
Everything is fine.
Oh, it's so dark.
Wait, is it laggy for you guys?
Where am I supposed to go?
I feel like I just...
Oh, it's this way.
Sorry, guys.
I went in the wrong...
Wow, my Marines live longer, too.
It's actually crazy.
My...
Don't...
Dennis is actually twice as fast as...
Don't know what to say.
Please just do it here.
Wow,
I can actually casually walk through everything.
Wow, I can actually...
Wow!
I can just walk through the entire point!
Oh, does it lag?
Does this actually lag if I swap through?
Like that?
Okay, maybe like not.
There we go.
Does that actually lag if I do that?
Because it doesn't lag for me.
Oh my god, it's crazy.
This game suddenly got so easy.
Get
over here.
Get your ass over here.
Oh my god.
It's like a walk in the park.
It actually feels like a walk in the park right now.
at this level it has african sunbat and shackle snipers
that's your essence thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you where i don't know where to go sir
keep in mind that this is only one tier One tier below.
One tier below what I just went through.
I am so confused right now.
Oh, shit.
Please go ahead.
Okay, I don't want to.
Oh, they're right here.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
wait these guys actually hit harder still is there a sniper
there's a sniper somewhere there's a
all right we're there you are there
you are oh yeah the sniper is one shot right
there we go i need more ammo though i need a
There you go.
Oh my god, they're just shot by the Marine.
Give me.
Like, I don't even have to shoot him.
Every time I shoot him, the Marine got him.
There you go.
Oh, don't waste that.
Oh, too late.
late too late guys i might have needed to know that little
earlier
there we go relax come on find a minute
it's okay i got a lot of sniper ammo now
where is he getting shot by these guys
All right, it's fine.
There we go.
Get rid of these guys.
Oh my god.
I never saw a game I can actually stand still for more than
10 seconds.
That's wild.
I can actually stand still for longer than 10 seconds.
That's crazy.
I didn't know.
I don't know how that feels.
I need just to breathe.
I can actually, like, register what's going on in this game.
I...
Oh, my God.
He fucking lives.
I can actually, like, know what's going.
Comprehend.
It's no longer survival mode.
I'm up.
I had to actually breathe.
Oh my, that's where it was coming from.
All right.
What the- Oh!
I didn't realize.
Okay, the ship kills.
I thought it stopped.
Can I shoot that thing down?
No.
I thought I could kill it.
Oh, can I?
Oh, I can.
Okay.
How do I kill it?
Oh, not in this game?
Okay.
Oh, plasma grenade it?
I don't know if I can even...
Oh, it's God.
Goodbye.
Okay, it's God.
It's fine.
Oh, you didn't...
Send people out this time Yeah, I knew we'd win do you know
I felt like I was part of the war like it was just me that's
part of the war everyone else was just Casually hanging out
with me Like it's like John Halo's got this
They're like we don't worry John Halo there's gonna be five
All right
Where's the other guy?
We did it.
Sure, we.
All right, I'll go there.
Someone get a satchel on the gate.
Oh,
where did everybody go?
Hunters?
Oh shit Oh fuck not these guys again Oh fuck okay You just
need them to turn their backs on us Is this still the back
strategy?
Okay where's their backs?
Wait where are their backs?
Wait where are they?
First off Where are they?
Oh Oh my god, I almost got the back.
I almost got it.
Oh shit.
Oh it's bad.
Oh it's a sniper for hunters or that?
Come on.
Look the other way.
Turn around.
You don't have to shoot me like that.
Oh shit.
Oh it's two shots.
God damn.
You don't fuck this.
There we go.
One down.
Wait, is he?
Yeah, one down.
What?
Come on!
Alright, there we go.
Oh, for the neck?
Okay, so is it...
Which is better, neck or back?
Find a hole.
Stay put.
We'll come to you.
Yeah, fuck that box in particular.
I think we're bullets, though.
Any skin.
Oh, they're the same now.
So the pistol in the back doesn't work like last time.
I think they're all worms, honestly.
They're all very worm-like.
There's a sniper.
There was a sniper.
Sergeant, I need you on the turn.
Oh shit.
You'll have...
Wait, aren't you guys gonna come with me?
Okay, we got more plasma grenades.
Okay, nice.
More sniper ammo.
There you go.
Oh god, there's the bugs.
Jesus, it's so large.
Yeah, my Marines aren't living.
Who shot me?
No, 100%.
Hey, he was taking a smoke break.
He's like...
Oh shit!
It's five.
Oh, it's no longer fine.
The drone's...
Okay, it's five.
We grab this.
Fuck it.
Get rid of the bugs.
Get bugged.
Alright, that Marine fucking out in the open.
Okay, turn Marine, turn around.
Marine, the enemies are that way.
Bro, they're that way.
No, no, he's not.
He's turn around.
There we go.
Hey, he's that way.
There you go.
Don't worry, guys.
I definitely see him.
I steal any of your...
Okay, I might need you to die.
You might have the gun I need.
You might have ammo that I need.
So I might need you to die really quickly for me.
Oh, unless...
Oh!
Okay.
Alright, well, he did die for me.
It's okay, he did that.
Watch this, though.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, watch this, though.
Okay, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Wow!
Wait, where is he?
Okay, okay, he's way too far.
He's way...
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
360!
Where am I?
Where is he?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, 360!
Oh, I did hit him!
I did hit him, guys!
360!
Oh, my god, I need to like...
Okay, I just need to be...
Oh, my god, I keep forgetting he's out taking a smoke break
here.
My bad.
I...
What fucking killed me, though?
I just don't know what killed me.
Okay, that sniper is gone.
And then there's this guy on smoke break.
Oh, there he is.
Wait.
Fuck, okay.
Fuck!
Oh, wait, there's one here.
I got it!
him.
I...
That counts.
That counts, guys.
Okay, and then that guy is taking a smoke break.
All right.
Damn, that's 360, though.
I know, right?
Oh, my God.
I don't know where the counter sniper is.
Oh, my God, he's right here.
kill him.
Alright, we're good.
I hear it a little squeakers.
There's no fucking way.
There's no way that didn't hit him.
There we go.
The fact that I could actually kill him through that is
actually I'm glad gamers
don't look up but we're where is he he's trying to see he
got me he was behind me he was behind me oh my where did I
spot oh my god the counter-sniper is right here.
There you go.
Alright, I'm not fucking around anymore.
I'm no longer fucking around.
There we go.
No more 360s anymore, guys.
No more 360s.
No.
He was right there.
I'm locking it.
Fun is over.
Aww.
They ruined the fun.
I might actually be dead.
I didn't think they were gonna rush me here.
Fun has ended.
Your friends are dead.
Oh, shit.
There you go.
This could be on...
No, it cannot.
Don't fuck it.
That's five.
How many...
Okay, that was my last bullet.
I hope there's no sniper near me.
Alright.
Where is the sniper?
There you are.
I hate you.
We both...
He shot me first, too.
Get down from here.
Is that also a sniper?
Alright.
This is my own sniper.
Oh, I almost shot him.
There we go.
Did it.
Crash sites on the other side of this hotel, Chief.
Covenant are crawling all over it.
Follow me.
Okay, it's both dark.
Ooh, spooky.
Ooh.
Oh, shit!
There we go.
Just use this.
Wait, that shit is OP.
What the fuck?
Wait, the rifle is so strong.
Why would I not use this?
That's just gonna shoot at me.
I'm just gonna wait here.
I'll just wait here.
I don't think I can get the...
There you go.
Oh, I have one ammo left.
Oh!
Oh, maybe I should have saved that.
No, whoopsie.
I fucking hate you.
There you go.
I didn't realize how quick the ammo goes, to be perfectly
honest.
I thought I'd have more ammo.
I thought I'd have more.
I got him off of it.
I am.
Wait, I get to ride this now!
Yay!
Oh, I'm really bad with this.
The highest concentration of Covenant troops is directly
below the carrier.
It is?
How do I get there?
Get on board.
That bridge is the most direct route to the city center.
This car sucks.
This guy fucking sucks.
Oh wait, that one's damaged.
I guess this one would have been better.
Yeah, they're not very fast.
Oh, I can punch them off.
Oh, it has a boost.
Oh shit.
Okay, never mind.
My bad.
It's actually pretty decent.
I'm gonna say this is a pretty slow-ass car.
The ammo is unlimited, right?
I assume?
Yeah.
I assume the ammo is limited.
Unlimited, sir.
Oh, I go.
I just gotta go here.
I can't boost and shoot at the same time, which I don't like
about that.
That's one thing I don't like.
Can I run him over?
Oh.
I can, but I think I broke my car.
I think I broke my car.
I don't think that was worth it.
Alright.
Oh, he's dead.
Whee.
Oh, no.
Oh, I...
Okay, there you go.
Oh, yes.
That's where I chipped it on you.
Oh, shit.
I actually need to kill him so I can take his...
So I got the better car.
Okay, now I'll go for a car.
What?
He just fucking got on it?
Just like that.
That's it.
I'm exploding the car.
Oh, shit.
Unless my car explodes.
Wait.
I never thought about that.
That's right.
I should be fighting this car for now.
But thank you, the Akasufa!
Thank you, thank you!
Benship and Halo, UNSC and Amber, glad how the Jacko sniper
is treating you.
I'm glad we didn't make it to Legendary.
We didn't hit the goal for Legendary.
I'm very glad about that.
Thank God.
I know it's like taking off training wheels right now.
Not doing this part unless after getting off of Legendary.
Wait, I want to grab on, get onto his car.
How do I hijack it?
No!
Lots of...
Thank you, thank you!
I'm glad we didn't make it.
I'm glad.
Oh, I just pressed E on it.
That's it.
It's just that easy.
Alright, let's see what I can grab onto this.
Get over here.
get over it wait he just ran away wait he just ran away wait
i'm gonna get shot at by the ship because he just ran all
right come on let me no i i really want to steal this car
oh my god give me a sec my ghost my ghost is flipping oh if
i plasma pistol the Ghost ill-disabled.
Okay, that's good to know actually.
No!
I flipped it!
I- No!
Oh shit, actually, okay, that's my bad.
I accidentally might have- oh no, my- is about to die.
I just need to make sure I don't hit any hard surfaces.
And I'm hitting on every hard surfaces on the planet.
Give me your fucking ship.
No!
God damn it!
I've been trying to kidnap the ship!
That's it.
I'm locking in now.
I'm mad.
Oh, fuck.
There's no way.
There's no way my gun that's perfectly trapped.
I just want to kidnap it.
That's all I want to do.
I just want to steal your car.
Is that too much to ask?
for?
Apparently it is.
I can't just fucking kidnap somebody's car.
I can't.
I did.
I pressed E.
Oh, it doesn't disable cars?
Who lied?
Who gave me false information?
info
oh my god oh my god i did it oh thank you oh now johnson is
here oh now he's here thanks johnson now he shows up oh god
no nice ship i spent seven deaths trying to get it we're up
the ladder i gotta climb up the ladder this guy.
That's right.
I'll beat you up.
Hold on.
All right.
I'll get rid of him in the car.
But we're it.
Why is he here?
Just sitting there.
That's all right.
The car will be fine.
I'm pretty sure.
He's fine.
See?
The car is about to explode, but I think they're fine.
I...
The Scarab gun?
Who had it?
Was it that guy up top?
Grab it.
This one?
No, that's...
No, that's the plasma rifle.
Who had the Scarab gun?
Where the fuck that gun is?
Oh, it's...
Not at this level, okay.
I was like, I don't think I remember seeing anybody carry a
Sierra blow gun.
Oh, shit.
Sorry, I was trying to find a gun.
That was my bad.
Oh, oh, my bad.
My car!
Oh, God.
Oh,
he came back.
Alright, guys.
Get out.
Hey, it's my turn.
Oh my god, he's driving for me too.
That's right.
Safety first.
It's my turn.
New car.
Alright, I just hope he like...
Rew.
Guys, I need you to not do a loop to the...
loop maybe drive towards the enemy i would really appreciate
that maybe like drive towards the people in front of us not
do a little a little loop to loop i think i'm hitting them i
think i have new car who's this okay nice nice nice we're
getting closer nice the ai is learning chat the ai is
learning it is possible he's learning
all right all right nice oh shit we're doing it that's right
what we're gonna do against two cars with guns this tunnel
links up to the bridge it's full of rats if you know what i
mean but it beats swimming yeah wow i feel happier for some
reason uh my my happiest level jumped jumped up 10 times
after starting this level to be here not even me all of us
can't i can't tell why though we got three cars oh my god
what's better than two cars three cars
strange I'm just happy to be outside.
You're right.
It's because I'm touching grass now.
It's because I get to touch grass.
Wait, what's this?
Is that a needleer?
What?
At least I got a needleer, though.
Okay, I didn't know there was friendly fire.
I didn't realize.
Friendly fire exists in this.
Guys, how was I supposed to know that?
Alright, now I know.
Do not classic AI.
Apparently, what, is it behind me?
Can I still grab it?
Oh my god, it's so far away.
It's so far away, wherever it is.
Cart Mershal, that man.
He killed them for their ammo.
Turn the favor.
I mean, none of these look like it.
Oh, my cars are gone.
So now I have to walk all the way there.
There's ghosts scattered around?
What does that mean?
Court-martial him.
Oh, I still have...
I guess the...
Oh, that ghost.
Your Honor, that man was drunk.
Someone said the scarab was here.
I was like, where?
Oh my god, you made me walk all the way there.
You're like, no, you missed the gun!
I was like, I missed, oh my god, now there's bugs.
Now there's bugs.
Now I'm alone.
They left me.
Now I'm fucking alone.
And I have...
Oh god, this is bad.
This is so bad.
I have actually...
The only gun I have is the needle.
oh and i oh all right who was it who was the guy give me his
name who told me to go back give me his name right now i
give give me his name right who was it who said that who
said the scare gun was back there but it wasn't back there
give me his name right now give me
I saw him.
He was crying about it too.
And I was like, you know what?
I'll be a nice person instead of ignoring that.
I'll go back.
I'll back back.
He's like, oh, he's crying.
I'll go back and see.
Check for him myself.
Who was it?
Who was he?
Who said that?
Who the fuck said that?
Who?
Who told me to go back?
Who told me?
Okay.
There we go.
But it's almost impossible to get.
He played.
Oh, there they are.
There they fucking are.
Come back.
Please, come back.
I want to be part of this.
Alright, I'm coming back.
I'll never leave my car again.
Now that I've learned my lesson.
That's why this is why I have trust issues This is why I
have trust issues guys, you know, I'll drive and fuck this
I'm gonna drive get out of here Okay, that's I said I'll
drive all right get over here Get out someone you get on top
You shoot You shoot You go...
Okay, whatever.
I'm leaving you.
Whatever.
I'm leaving.
Oh, he came back.
Okay, that is.
Oh, that looks very dangerous.
Alright, shoot him.
Shoot him.
Alright, that's fine.
Oh, wait.
That's just better.
Wait, that's actually better.
Oh, yes.
Wait, I can honk by horror now.
Oh, nice.
Alright, please.
Give me...
Alright, there's...
All right, so that guy wanted me to do an almost impossible
glitch on my first time.
That's crazy.
I think he had too much expectations of...
I'm leaving the car.
You're going to explode in that car.
That guy had too much expectations on me as a gamer.
If he really thinks I was going to pull off an almost
impossible glitch on my first playthrough.
Yeah.
There you go.
Jesus, you're still going at it?
Okay, that's me being a little too overconfident with this
part.
There you go.
Alright, guys.
You guys finally showed up.
Thanks, guys.
We believe in you, Doki.
At least someone believes in me.
Oh, where those explosive arrows, they look very similar.
safe for some reason.
Yeah, that guy's car is definitely gonna explode for sure.
Yeah, I'm just gonna look from here.
Yeah, okay, I can see people from up here.
That's good.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, my tailpipe!
Okay, now I can see from here.
Oh, shit!
I'm doing a wheelie right now.
Alright, goodbye.
I think I can't see.
I have to swap graphics.
There we go.
One more down.
Oh, wait.
Can I, like, get on top of this?
Oh, fuck this.
No, never mind.
Not that.
That's too far.
That's too much walking.
I got off and I realized I'm not about that.
There we go.
Wait, there's another...
Am I?
Oh, that's too much walking.
I'm gonna go back.
Where's the driver?
Oh, there you are.
There we go.
That should cause a traffic jam, right?
I'm actually curious.
Will that cause a traffic jam?
Yeah, that did.
see guys it's a strat I get rid of the first car and then
they all have to stop now
see strategy who's still alive
get out of here all right flip Oh my god, I made the flip
too.
I think I lost all my men.
But it's alright.
I'm still alive.
That's all that matters.
I'm still here.
Whoa.
Oh, alright.
It's fine.
My thing is a...
Boom!
Bumper car situation right now.
Alright, I think I should have to get off of this though.
I'm gonna have to try and steal.
another car oh fuck oh i got pincered
i can't even tell which one's the hd graphics and which
one's the low graphics anymore i okay they all do not look
very well in this area in this one area okay i think this is
hd it's brighter it's bright i literally couldn't tell
anymore because it really blends in They're both very
different graphics, but they both do not look HD.
I need to get rid of him.
Oh, fuck!
I exploded!
It's just gray.
A tunnel is a tunnel.
Okay, this has to be HD.
It's shot here.
We're gonna be in this corner.
That's right.
Collision- oh!
Never mind.
Halo 2 has his own version, but it's the main best being
beat only by the ODTS ST.
Luca, thank you.
The Alca's too fun.
Thank you.
Yeah, we've been, like, bouncing in between the graphics.
Oh, thank you.
The Alca's too fun.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
It's so dark.
I have to, like, always swap graphics when it gets too dark.
Is that a new ghost?
Oh, wait.
That is not.
That is an old ghost.
Which I shall now blow up.
That's right.
Which ghost is going to blow up first?
It could be mine.
Oh, nice.
I have new ammo.
What the fuck?
I don't even know how to turn on the flashlight, guys.
Am I still shooting him?
I can't tell.
He's, like, always looking at me.
like him oh no that one's dead for real
he dead he's dead alright nice now I have zero ghost
what do I do I have no bikes now no bitches no bikes oh wait
that car wait I think that car is still alive unless I think
that car is still alive.
Oh, and he's still alive, too.
I thought he was dead.
I mean, I guess.
Oh, my God.
There's no way you live there.
There is no way you actually live that.
He just casually fucking gets off bikes.
Just gets off the bike.
I'm sad now.
Now I have no bikes.
Unless...
Is this bike still alive?
Oh, there we go.
Barely.
I'll take what I can get.
He bailed out.
I thought he would die with the ship.
You know?
Oh my god, we made it.
Oh my god.
That took...
Like, an hour.
That took a lot less of a time.
An hour versus three.
Where's the rest of your flotone?
Wasted Sarge.
And we will be too, sir.
If we don't get the hell out of here.
I wonder how they all die.
No, sir.
Then listen up.
When I joined the car, we didn't.
have any fancy schmancy tanks we had sticks two sticks and a
rock for a whole platoon and we had to share the rock fuck
up boy you're one very lucky marine what about that scarab
we've all run the simulations the scarab ain't invincible
stay with the master jeep he'll know what to do yes sir
sergeant i definitely know what to do he never gets me
anything Damn right, Sarge.
Ladies like grinding trees.
Damn right.
So what is the scarab?
There's the scorpion.
Oh my god.
I need to stop myself.
I have to throw stuff through.
Oh, okay.
I know, guys.
I know, I know it sucks, but I actually have to stop right
here.
I have to stop right here because I do have stuff to record.
behind the scenes.
So we're gonna have to call it here, guys.
We're gonna call it here.
Don't worry.
Next week, we will find out what I will find out what the
Scarab is.
I will find out.
But we made it.
We actually were able to beat one level.
One level on Legendary.
It took me an hour 30 minutes to figure out the combo but we
did it guys and that's all that matters we fucking did it
I hope you guys enjoyed my suffering for that first level I
I did not know what I was getting myself into I did not know
what I was getting myself into on when I went to ledger but
now I know now I know
now I figured it out I figured out the combo that was a
journey I was a fucking journey
oh my god but thank you guys i hope you guys enjoyed my
first time trying halo 2 and my first time trying legendary
i didn't even do legendary on the halo 1 i was like no you
guys don't got me there i was like it's like no no i did
heroic on on halo 1 but i was like no no no legendary you
guys got me you guys got me there um i hope you guys enjoy
How many levels is Halo 2?
I'm two out of how many.
I do want to know.
But you're saying it was a great...
It was a great journey.
Pete, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, 2 out of 13.
We're getting 2 out of 13 levels in 4 hours.
Sorry, 2 out of 15 in 4 hours.
hours what a record anyway i'm gonna go i'm gonna go do
works down the sea's work so i did want to play more but i
can tell my voice is actually sort of dying now and i do
have some stuff i have to record so i'm gonna rest my voice
a little bit do with some recordings and but i hope you guys
had a fun time watching today's stream um and watching my
first attempt at halo 2 and at legendary level as always
everybody say hi drain pause to check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing if you still for me head to bed
because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody
bye guys bye